man working outside is the greatest it's
the best I I smell like mother Gaia in
order to work remotely you want to put
together the perfect gaggle of gadgets
and you don't want to overload your bag
with unnecessary junk what's the first
thing that you wanted to get laptop
actually not even a laptop I needed a
netbook something those small fast they
could access the internet on and I could
also do word docs but there's a lot of
netbooks being made now so I guess
what's sort of the best one that you
think's coming out that you found that
you wanted to try out it doesn't have
the atom processor in it it's got the
the via processor in it so it's faster
than any other netbook on the market we
tested this and it turned out better
benchmarks than the MSI then the asus
then the HP netbooks so we gave it like
a 9 out of 10 we give it a nine out of
10 currently it's our favorite
ultraportable wow notebook right now the
biggest gripe that we have with you know
mobile gadgets is that they get beat up
a lot so we need something as maybe you
know maybe if you if you're harsh on
things you need something's a little bit
more durable
really geared more towards scientists
people who enjoyed an obstruction out in
the field and it's perfectly waterproof
what's it like to use it though like if
I was to I don't know try it out to try
to edit a word document on it I mean
what would that be like it's not bad
it's all t nine okay so it doesn't
actually have a qwerty keypad which is
which is mildly annoying but on the
other hand it I think it's a lot faster
than trying to do like an iPhone Touch
you know touchscreen what okay so here's
a good question i have an iphone whoa
you know why would i get this instead of
an iphone I'm really glad you asked that
question internet yes that's okay
problem when your mobile right right
right totally that's that's like the
biggest problem even here in San
Francisco we'd it's a great Wi-Fi town
we don't even have meanness of a
wireless no we don't what this does is
this grabs cellular signal and from
verizon and then it regurgitates that as
a as Wi-Fi signal you can hook up to
five pcs so it barfs up internet it
barfs up internet lost me at regurgitate
okay outside but now let's talk about
some of the other things you'll want to
have when you're working outdoors this
thing right here is from Hammacher
smeller feller and with this look it
looks like a harmless laptop bag but
breaking it out and it's a actual full
fully functioning director's chair it's
a hundred and thirty dollars which is
expensive yes it's nine pounds so a
hundred and thirty dollars you know / 9
pounds is by the pound however I'm it's
it's aluminum and steel frame it can
hold up to 250 pounds that's almost
enough that's almost enough of you and
me to sit together on it this is the
chrome Warsaw yeah and it is pretty much
the largest bag ever made its enormous
so it has different slots and spots so
you can have your your work computer you
could have your personal computer and
then you can fit a change of clothes oh
don't forget your protection you can fit
your your helmet inside for cycling and
for mobile you know mobile office
instead of doing a messenger bag which
is going to really kind of pull on one
side or one shoulder you get an even way
distribution on the two and you also
have this padded back so nothing's going
to poke you in the back so let's talk
about the tandem bike um I first of all
I was really shocked that we'd never
crashed here's the way the tandem works
there's you know one guy in the front
the captain that would be me and then
there's another guy in the back that
would be him the stochastic ER as of now
I mean I think we had a fully
functioning office outdoors for a couple
hours and it was wonderful I no matter
up my productivity went way up I
couldn't be happier with my productivity
yeah team building together always
forever and forever